hi this is my vision for the Africa that
I would like to see in the next 15 to 25
years I see an Africa that is at peace
with himself I see in Africa that is a
respectable in the global scheme of
things and Africa that contributes to
the development of the whole world we
will achieve this she's very strong and
visionary leadership that seeks to
educate his citizens prepare them for
the digital revolution that you are
going through we will be doing this
through investment in infrastructure
that integrates our entire continent we
will achieve this through very very
strong focus on ICT this is the kind of
thought of Africa that we are looking
for and this is the kind of Africa that
our generation will be making sure that
we deliver on thank you